مشاهدينا نعود مره اخرى الى خبر الطير
نيبالي حيث اعلن السلطات والمطار نيبال ان
من بين ركاب الطائره المنكوبه فرنسيسيا
واسترالي وارجنتيني رئيس وزراء نيبال كان
في هذا السياق اللي في اجتماع طارق
الحكومه بعد كارثه تحطم طائره الركاب كما
اعلن ايضا متحدث باسم جيش نيبال وفاه 16
مرتفع على الاقل متابعين هذا الخبر العجل
المشاهدين شركه الطيران في نيبال تتحدث عن
همم وجود 15 اجنبيه من بين ركاب الطائره
المنكوبه الى التاكد حتى الان وجود خمسه
10 15 اجنبيه يبين ركاب الطائره المنكو-
المنكوبه منهم خمسه هنود واربعه رؤوس
وكوريين جنوبيه وايرلندي بين الركاب
الطائره المنكوبه ايضا مشاهدينا اكد شركه
الطيران ان 10
اجانب هذا اذا بعد التحديث تاكد ان هناك
15 اجنبيا يبين ركاب الطائره وليس عشرات
اجانب كما ذكر في بدايه هذا الخبر